Nó này mùng sinh tháng 2 năm 2018, tỏa như dân tình đồng này bởi vì tỏa sế sử dân thầm bị gáo lươi sĩ tùng
3 mi ba tuổi về các tự dết người, cứ tài sản, tảng chứ vận chuyển, sử dụng, mô bàn trái phép bu khía quân dụng và vị hoại tài sản.
Cung vụ an, còn có các vị gáo khác bị đưa ra sế sử, quôn, lưu mình tính, tổ chế tạo, tảng chứ, mô bàn trái phép bu khía quân dụng,
tỏa tảng chứ, sử dụng, mô bàn trái phép bu khía quân dụng và phẩm quân vị tổng mô bàn trái phép bu khía quân dụng.
Hôm tâm sử nhận định hành viết của vị gáo lươi sĩ tổn mất nhìn tính, chỉ trong thể rằng
anh đã sỡ tài sất khải bang với trong gia đình trong khi cơ nộ nhân khổному thống gì đưa quảy bị gáo.
Nó lời sâu cũng, các bị gáo đều mong hộ đồng sế sử dụng xem xam ăn thất xóm mức đến nghĩ của vị đại dựng bị kiểm sát,
dân bị gáo tùng hung nói lời xâu cũng.
Hồi đồng sẽ sự quyết định tương phạt bị gáo lên sĩ tụng mất an từ hình về tội giết người
Mấy năm tù về tội cưới tại sản, bốn năm tù về về tội tạng trước, vẫn chuyển, sự dụng
Một bản chế phép bục hí quyền dụng và một năm tù về tội vị hoại tại sản
Tong ở kinh phạt chung là tự hình, bị gáo lưu mình tính bị phạt bán năm tù về tội tội giết tạo
Tạng trước, một bản chế phép phép phục hí quyền dụng
Mến văn biệt bị phạt hai năm sau tháng về tội tạng trước, sự dụng
Một bản chế phép bục hí quy quy quy quy phật một năm tù về tội một bản chế phép bục hí quyền dụng